buonasera le origini e il tema di oggi
quando mi hanno chiesto di partecipare
al the backs ero molto emozionata lo
sono ancora adesso la prima cosa che ho
fatto è andare nel bosco e cercare di
capire che cosa significava questo
questa parola molto importante di
cercare di qual era il tema che volevo
portarvi oggi io sono ludovica rubini
sono un'imprenditrice agricola sono una
moglie sono una mamma ma soprattutto
sono una donna che ha un sogno vivo
cortina d'ampezzo che è un piccolissimo
paese di 6 mila abitanti è un paese che
nonostante la sua notorietà è un paese
dove vivono persone molto umili grandi
lavoratori dove vivono persone che nella
loro vita
cercano sempre ogni giorno di preservare
la loro provenienza le loro origini
siamo dentro le dolomiti
siamo in uno dei posti più belli del
mondo un patrimonio dell'unesco e ho
capito vivendoli che chi nasce ma
soprattutto chi vive nella bellezza avrà
sempre più star up sempre più propenso
nella salvaguardia del territorio e
delle proprie origini
quando sono andata a vivere a cortina
ero molto giovane e all'inizio mi sono
sentita subito spaesata non mi sentivo a
mio agio e ho cercato di prendere il
buono dalle cose che facevo andavo
spesso nel bosco e camminavo e nel bosco
ho capito che quello che pensavo fosse
una situazione di disagio in realtà era
una forza che mi stava nascendo dentro
perché questo bosco mi ha lasciato
questa forza
ero lì in quel punto davanti alle
montagne
avevo un ruscello a fianco e c'era quel
profumo d'aria quel profumo che si sente
quando c'è stata una tempesta quando
tagliano degli alberi e cioè quell odore
di resina per me in montagna profuma
anche l'acqua i quattro elementi
io oggi vi vorrei portare in un percorso
fatto di quattro elementi quattro
elementi perché i quattro elementi sono
all'origine di ognuno di noi e io li
vivo un pochino come se fossero delle
mie tappe nella vita vi voglio parlare
quello che di quello che per me è
origine e vorrei farlo facendo di fare
questo sentiero
terra acqua aria e fuoco
sono questi gli elementi e sono convinta
che uno dei modi per tornare alle nostre
origini e riconnettersi con questi
elementi iniziamo terra
[Musica]
la terra sono le mie radici e ciò che mi
ha dato la spinta per iniziare questo
percorso lo chiamo percorso perché
secondo me la vita è un percorso fatto
di momenti in cui vinciam piano cadiamo
giriamo un angolo oscuro attraversando
una tempesta una zona famosa dove ci
manca l'aria però è anche latella il
percorso che noi ci costruiamo il che ci
costruiscono le persone che ci stanno
attorno la terra da dove sono partita la
terra sono le mie radici perché ognuno
di noi anche se non vuole ha delle
radici che ci tengono legati alle nostre
origini
ma queste radici ci devono dare anche la
spinta per andare avanti per essere
consapevoli che dobbiamo seguire ogni
giorno il nostro obiettivo
cortina non è la mia città d'origine io
sono bolognese e sono andata a vivere a
cortina 22 anni e questa mia avventura
iniziata con un cuore grande ma piedi
molto infantili oggi dopo 15 anni mi
rendo conto di affrontare la mia vita
con un cuore da bambina ma piedi molto
forti le mie origini il mio carattere
ottimista
allegro estroverso curioso ma aiutato
moltissimo nella mia vita nella
diventato nella mia vita professionale e
nella mia vita quotidiana la terra e
dove ti senti a casa ma la terra e
l'ambiente che ti ospita e ciò che ti
legherà per sempre
la mia casa è una casa con meno macchine
più cime è una casa con meno suoni e più
silenzi è una casa con meno asfalto è
più terra la terra è la genesi delle
origini acqua
[Musica]
mamma dov'è il rubinetto dei fiumi
questa è stata una delle domande di mia
figlia sicilia iodio bambine ccd e
clementina nell'età dei perché che tutti
i genitori sanno a che cosa si va
incontro quotidianamente
mi ha fatto questa domanda che
all'inizio mi ha lasciata un pochino con
delle domande stesse a me poi ho cercato
di pensare a che cosa poterle rispondere
e mi sono chiesta dove nasce l'acqua
finirà mai
l'acqua l'ho sempre immaginata come un
elemento da invidiare l'acqua scorre
l'acqua ci dà una speranza perché se le
piante nascono e crescono e grazie
all'acqua uno dei miei ricordi più belli
di quando ero bambina andavo nel bosco i
miei genitori a fare dei picnic ci
fermavamo sempre in un prato a fianco al
ruscello
questo perché ci dava sicuramente pace
ci permetteva di abbeverarci ci
permetteva di giocare nei bambini
nell'acqua e lì ho capito che l'acqua
nasce in montagna e nasce pura perché
ero abituato a vedere l'acqua in città
non sempre pulitissima e nasce sempre da
una sorgente nascosta l'acqua
diciamo che è un elemento meraviglioso
vi dicevo l'acqua scorre l'acqua il
simbolo della purificazione
l'acqua e speranza l'acqua non si ferma
non è un muro
l'acqua non emergevano la mano in un
fiume
sentiamo solo una carezza l'acqua è
libera perché va dove vuole andare
noi niente le si può porre
l'acqua a logora e consuma una pietra
senza avere mai fretta ma con costanza
l'acqua che idrata nutre e vorrei
ripetermi un concetto l'acqua che
gocciola consuma una pietra lo vorrei
ripetere perché io nella mia vita quando
davanti a me ho avuto un ostacolo ho
cercato di prendere esempio dall'acqua o
gocciolato quando dovevo consumare
oppure ho girato attorno quando volevo
arrivare al mio obiettivo con speranza
con fermezza e con lentezza
aria
[Musica]
ed ora vi chiedo di chiudere un attimo
gli occhi
e di fare un respiro
immaginatevi il silenzio della montagna
la sua maestosità
immaginatevi il vuoto sotto i piedi
il freddo di una roccia
il respiro affannato
immaginatevi di essere in cima a una
montagna
vicino all'area
pieni di aria
ecco molti dei ricordi miei profumano di
aria io e riccardo mio marito mi ha
portato a fare una ferrata un giorno
molto difficile eravamo in cima a una
montagna
io e lui li lui ha capito che era la
donna per lui
io l'avevo già capito in parte in quel
momento pro fumavamo d'aria
quell'area che ancora oggi quando sento
mi riporta esattamente in quel momento
in quel posto perché l'aria fa questo
l'area trasporta ogni cosa pulisce il
cielo ci dà respiro l'aria è l'origine
l'aria è l'elemento che decide della
nostra sopravvivenza è potente pauroso
ma e anche potente delicato l'aria e
ogni o dovunque mia figlia clementina
che ama sciare profumo ad aria quando
torna a casa
l'area ci chiede di non esagerare
quando abbiamo un momento di ansia basta
chiudere gli occhi e respirare e questo
ci riporta esattamente in sintonia col
nostro corpo col nostro mondo
io mi sento come l'aria questo è
l'elemento che più mi avvicina esisto mi
sento
ma non vedo ciò che ho fatto ma cerco di
guardare ciò che farò e ora vi chiedo di
fare l'ultimo respiro chiudendo gli
occhi
ogni nostro respiro deve essere una
promessa da mantenere con la natura il
soffio di vita delle origini
acqua fuoco aria
ora siamo a fuoco grazie
[Musica]
allora l'unione del fuoco dell'acqua
formano simbolo dell'anima umana il
fuoco è l'origine con la o maiuscola e
la forza profonda ed è il motore della
rigenerazione il fuoco e convivialità e
famiglia
il fuoco estate e inverno
il mio ricordo più bello ricordo molto
recente eravamo a settembre durante il
nostro evento genesis un evento che come
focus aveva il ritorno alle origini
volevamo parlare della natura del cibo
delle persone
l'ultima sera abbiamo allestito un campo
di tende in mezzo alla natura in una
conca di larici volevamo cucinare solo
con il fuoco
abbiamo fatto lo zabaione
abbiamo messo due ore a fare quello
zabaione ma è stato lo zabaione più
buona della mia vita
durante questo evento avevamo invitato
chef da tutta europa
sponsor importanti che ci avevano
supportato per fare l'evento giornalisti
c'erano i nostri clienti che sono le
persone più importanti per noi e questo
fuoco ha fatto una cosa incredibile ha
creato una magia
davanti a questo fuoco ci siamo sentiti
tutti uguali ci ha tolto da tutti gli
status titoli di studio questo fuoco ci
ha fatto sentire piccolissimi di fronte
alla natura ci ha fatto sentire alle
origini dell'essere umano
qualche tempo fa abbiamo iniziato a
parlare di cucina rigenerativa un
concetto per me molto importante
ne abbiamo l'azienda agricola da noi il
prodotto nasce viene portato sulla
tavola e quello che viene sprecato viene
riportato in azienda come mangime per
gli animali per gli animali il fuoco
protagonista dell'ultima serata di
genesys ci ha insegnato quale sarebbe
stata la nostra missione
la mia missione
è da riportare tutto alle origini con la
semplicità con la quale lo fanno questi
quattro elementi di cui vi ho parlato
oggi è quattro elementi che lo
compongono
la nostra missione e cercare di compiere
un grandissimo salto verso la
rigenerazione umana grazie
[Applauso]